back sitting sitting here I miss mr.
Kevin Nealon and this is unusual you're
going to sketch me
that's right Conan and you you've
learned this these are like the people
on the boardwalk they watch these people
growing up like a lot of us have you
know since this musing they ask a lot of
questions the next thing you know the
pictures finished so ok I've been taking
some art classes I'm very excited with
the progress I've been making and I
appreciate you sitting for me like I
look ok here this is a good look great
ok here we go ok here we go I'm gonna do
my best now Conan ok here we go okay so
: you out here in vacation no I'm
hosting a television show any one of the
guests
yeah I've been living here a long time
yeah you go to school I know I been a
talk show host for about 13 years yeah
you like you like school if I were in
school I'm sure I'd be enjoying it but
I'm just about finished here yeah run
into our front a little bit of a problem
I can start up a little bit higher now
I'm a talk show host and I've been here
in New York in your studio for 13 and
you like it out here yeah school no I
don't go to school
okay okay I'll still cuz it knows is the
hardest feature no I'll give me a nice
smile now there Conan here we go
good nice relaxed smile good
got it that's a better smile that's a
better smile that's a better smile yeah
I can tell this is gonna be good yeah
Connor what is your favorite sport
uh baseball all right hockey it is knock
it is gonna sign it before I gotta like
this sign it all right now let me get
the eyes the eyes are the hardest
feature to get you have beautiful gray
hazel blue green blue blue yeah alright
just a little bit we're the sunglasses I
want to cover up my mistakes and then
we'll make it a funny picture put on a
tip your nose will make it funny like
this like like that not that funny get
it up there
[Applause]
you're really helpful here all right now
let me say let me at this side yeah one
ear and you got two ears when you say
yes get what I say ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
I want you to have their skirt
I want you to have that Conan be careful
do not get that on your clothes it does
not come off you horrible horrible man
Kevin's gonna be at the Tampa Bay
Performing Arts Center December 15th and
the parker playhouse in fort lauderdale
on december 16th season 3 of weeds airs
on showtime next summer
that's correct you're a scholar and a
gentleman thank you Kevin you and
everybody
[Applause]